>>We have schools because
we hope that someday
when children have left schools
that they will still be able
to use what it is that
they've learned.
And there is now a massive amount of
evidence from all realms of science
that unless individuals take a
very active role in what it is
that they're studying, unless
they learn to ask questions,
to do things hands-on, to essentially
recreate things in their own mind
and then transform them as is
needed, the ideas just disappear.
The student may have a
good grade on the exam.
We may think that he or
she is learning, but a year
or two later there's nothing left.
If, on the other hand, somebody has
carried out an experiment himself
or herself, analyzed the data, made
a prediction and saw whether it came
out correctly; if somebody
is doing history
and actually does some interviewing
himself or herself, oral histories,
then reads the documents,
listens to it,
go back and asks further
questions, writes up a paper--
that's the kind of thing
that's going to adhere,
where if you simply memorize a
bunch of names and a bunch of facts
and a bunch of-- even
a bunch of definitions,
there's nothing to hold onto.
The idea of multiple intelligences
comes out of psychology.
It's a theory that was
developed to document the fact
that human beings have very different
kinds of intellectual strengths
and that these strengths are very,
very important in how kids learn
and how people represent
things in their minds,
and then how people use them in order
to show what it is that
they've understood.
If we all had exactly the same kind
of mind and there was only one kind
of intelligence, then we could
teach everybody the same thing
in the same way and assess them in
the same way, and that would be fair.
But once we realize that people
have very different kinds of minds,
different kinds of strengths--
some people are good in thinking
spatially, some people are good
in thinking language, other people
are very logical, other people need
to do hands-on; they need
to actually explore actively
and to try things out-- once
we realize that, then education
which treats everybody the same way
is actually the most unfair education
because it picks out
one kind of mind,
which I call the Law Professor
Mind, somebody who's very linguistic
and logical, and says, "If
you think like that, great.
If you don't think like that, there's
no room in the train for you."
If we know that one child
has a very spatial--
a visual or spatial way of learning,
another child has a very hands-on way
of learning, a third child likes to
ask deep philosophical questions,
a fourth child likes stories,
we don't have to talk
very fast as a teacher.
We can actually provide software,
we can provide materials,
we can provide resources which
present material to a child in a way
in which the child will find
interesting and will be able
to use his or her intelligences
productivity, and to the extent
that the technology is interactive,
the child will actually be able
to show his or her understanding in a
way that's comfortable to the child.
We have this myth that the only
way to learn something is read it
in a textbook or hear a lecture
on it, and the only way to show
that we've understood something
is to take a short-answer test
or maybe occasionally with
an essay question thrown in.
But that's nonsense.
Everything can be taught
in more than one way,
and anything that's understood
can be shown in more than one way.
I don't believe because there
are eight intelligences we have
to teach things eight ways.
I think that's silly.
But we always ought to
be asking to ourselves,
"Are we reaching every
child, and if not,
are there other ways
in which we can do it?"
I think that we teach
way too many subjects
and we cover way too much
material, and the end result is
that students have a very
superficial knowledge--
as we often say, a mile
wide and an inch deep--
and then once they leave school,
almost everything's been forgotten.
And I think that school needs to
change to have a few priorities
and to really go into those
priorities very deeply.
So let's take the area of science.
I actually don't care if a child
studies physics or biology or geology
or astronomy before
he goes to college.
There's plenty of time to do
that kind of detailed work.
I think what's really
important is to begin to learn
to think scientifically, to
understand what a hypothesis is,
how to test it out and see
whether it's working or not;
if it's not working, how to
revise your theory about things.
That takes time.
There's no way you can present that
in a week or indeed even in a month.
You have to learn about it from doing
many different kinds of experiments,
seeing when the results are
like what you predicted,
seeing when they're
different, and so on.
But if you really focus on science in
that kind of way, by the time you go
to college-- or, if you don't go
to college, by the time you go
to workplace-- you'll know the
difference between a statement
which is simply a matter
of opinion or prejudice,
and one for which there's
solid evidence.
The most important thing about
assessment is knowing what it is
that you should be able to do.
And the best way for me to think
about it is a child learning a sport
or a child learning an
art form, because they're
as completely un-mysterious-- what
you have to be to be a quarterback
or a figure skater
or a violin player.
You see it, you try it
out, you're coached.
You know when you're getting better.
You know how you're doing
compared to other kids.
In school, assessment is mystifying.
Nobody knows what's
going to be on the test,
and when the test results go back,
neither the teacher nor the
student knows what to do.
So what I favor is highlighting
for kids from the day they walk
into school what are the performances
and what are the exhibitions
for which they're going
to be accountable.
Let's get real.
Let's look at the kinds of things
that we really value in the world.
Let's be as explicit as we can.
Let's provide feedback to kids
from as early as possible,
and then let them internalize
the feedback
so they themselves can say what's
going well, what's not going so well.
I'm a writer, and initially I had to
have a lot of feedback from editors,
including a lot of rejections.
But over time, I learned what was
important, I learned to edit myself,
and now the feedback from
editors is much less necessary.
And I think anybody as an adult knows
that as you get to be more expert
in things you don't have to do
so much external critiquing;
you can do what we
call self-assessment.
And in school, assessment shouldn't
be something that's done to you.
It should be something where
you are the most active agent.
I think for there to be longstanding
change in American education--
that is widespread rather
than just on the margins--
first of all people have to see
examples of places which are
like their own places where the
new kind of education really works,
where students are learning deeply,
where they can exhibit
their knowledge publicly,
and where everybody who
looks at the kids says,
"That's the kind of
kids I want to have."
So we need to have
enough good examples.
Second of all, we need to have
the individuals who are involved
in education, primarily teachers
and administrators, believe in this,
really want to do it, and get the
kind of help that they need in order
to be able to switch, so to
speak, from a teacher-centered,
"Let's stuff it into the
kid's mind" kind of education,
to one where the preparation
is behind the scenes
and the child himself or herself
is at the center of learning.
Third of all, I think we need
to have assessment schemes
which really convince everybody that
this kind of education is working.
It does no good to have
child-centered learning
and then have the same
old multiple choice tests
which were used 50 or 100 years ago.
Finally, I think there has to be
a political commitment which says
that this is the kind of education
which we want to have in our country,
and maybe outside this country,
for the foreseeable future.
And as long as people are busy
bashing teachers or saying
that we can't try anything
new because it might fail,
then reform will be stifled
as it has been in the past.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org